in the history of the human race every
society there's always people that want
to impose control on the people and
there's another group that wants Freedom
I've been I've been reading conceived in
Liberty which is Mary rothbard's history
of the American colonies before the
Revolutionary War
and it's hundreds of chapters Non-Stop
struggle someone wants to control a
colony they want to tell you what to
think they want to tell you you know
what you know who God is they want to
Define religion they want to impose
taxes they want to seize your property
they want to tax your property they want
to impose monopolies and then there's
another group fighting for freedom